So Georgi Tsvetkov said that Vitaly Laletin, without juice, would be just a tall, skinny guy, because he's not a real super heavyweight.
Just listen. For me, Vitaly is very overrated.
You mean overrated? Overrated, yeah. Very overrated.
He's not truly a heavyweight.
He's just a skinny, tall guy with, you know, too much juice.
Without the juice, maximum one hundred kilograms. Maximum.
Okay, so I think that's a pretty good starting point for our discussion about body weight in armwrestling.
Because I think we don't actually understand how much a person can weigh in this sport without carrying unnecessary fat that benefits you in, I don't know, what.
But yeah, we're just going to go through this.
I prepared some things and checked some sources, if you want to see them.
This is the reference for this video.
I made a summary from it, some tables, and after this you're going to have, I would say, a pretty good idea of how much a person without gear use can weigh without having too much fat.
And maybe that will change your approach a little bit to diet, to general thinking about armwrestling, or the state of today's armwrestling.
So there are a few things that need to be said at the beginning.
I took bodybuilders as a reference point, because if someone is trying for a decade to get big, I assume that no one else can get as big as this person.
And because armwrestling is about being better at armwrestling, not being bigger.
So as a ceiling, I'm taking bodybuilders, because they are just bigger.
In this case, we have a study from nineteen ninety-five, which is a very good study that was used multiple times to determine what is naturally possible, or what is not possible, for humankind and the human body.
It uses FFMI, so Fat-Free Mass Index, which in my opinion is the best thing to use.
Okay, let's go further.
Here are the formulas and calculations.
If you want, make a screenshot, and correct me if I'm wrong at some point or if you don't agree with something.
This is transparent. This is how I did it.
So let's go straight to the first study.
There was a group of natural and not-natural lifters.
And here we have eighty-three users and seventy-four non-users. These guys were powerlifters, bodybuilders, strength athletes. They were not random guys from the gym. The average FFMI for non-users was around twenty-two, which is pretty good. I mean, it's really good, and it actually overlaps with other studies and ideas about how much muscle mass you can put on yourself.
Because this is roughly what you can get.
If you go on YouTube and check natural influencers who have been doing this for more than five years, this is what they will get, like twenty-one something.
And of course, steroid users were way, way bigger.
Oh, and the most important thing, right?
This is the average, but the highest non-user had twenty-five FFMI.
That was normalized FFMI above twenty-five.
And why normalized FFMI?
Because for tall people it gives bad results, and for very short people it gives bad results.
So you need to normalize it to one hundred eighty centimeters tall, and then it's more or less fair.
They also compared these results with the pre-gear era, with Mr. America winners, so the elite of the elite in bodybuilding. The guy who had the highest FFMI was Mr. Dillinger, with twenty-eight. We need to remember that this was not measured.
This was just an estimation, because they estimated it from photos, relations, body weight, and all that stuff. They didn't measure it.
So the highest measured in this study was twenty-five, and the highest estimated was twenty-eight, but on average, the winner of Mr. America was twenty-five point four.
So we can safely assume that if you have freakish genetics that allow you to win a bodybuilding contest,
and you spent a decade getting massive, twenty-five is something that you potentially can reach naturally.
Which obviously is not the case for armwrestlers, because we are not training glutes and we are not trying to get as big as we can.
We try to be strong, right? That's different. But anyway, let's go further.
Yeah, that's an interesting thing.
Modern-era bodybuilders range from twenty-six to thirty-nine.
That's ridiculous. I mean, okay.
Why fifteen percent body fat? There are plenty of studies on the dependence of testosterone on body fat, but there is none saying that at fifteen percent you have the best testosterone possible.
Okay, so I got it from a few studies. If you have more than twenty-one point four percent body fat, it's not optimal, because you have less testosterone. That's the first point of reference. So everything above twenty-one point five is not good for us. There is a study that examined the bottom end.
A natural bodybuilder spent twelve months preparing for a contest, participated, and then finished. In general, look at his testosterone. When he was at four point five percent body fat, his testosterone was on the floor. The best testosterone he had was at fourteen point six, or before that, fourteen point eight, so roughly around fifteen percent.
Also, I checked powerlifters, and there is a lot of data.
Usually they are from twelve to eighteen percent, with some exceptions for the heaviest guys.
But in powerlifting, yeah, never mind. I take fifteen percent.
For sure it's not twenty percent, okay?
It's somewhere between twelve and eighteen. It may differ by person, but it doesn't change the picture.
So if it's twelve or eighteen, or even twenty, it doesn't change the whole picture. That's why I took fifteen.
In my opinion, it would honestly be better to be around twelve.
Because then I think you have a competitive advantage by being a bit lighter, because it allows you to jump into a lower weight category.
If it does, obviously, because it depends on the situation.
So let's go further and see how much you can weigh while maxing out your muscle mass by spending decades or more and having this freakishly elite genetics,
like Ronnie Coleman, Arnold Schwarzenegger, or even better, Mr. Dillinger, with twenty-eight.
So for a one-hundred-eighty-centimeter guy, if you are Mr. Dillinger at fifteen percent body fat, you can be one hundred six kilos.
If you are more realistic, twenty-one point eight, which is already great, it's eighty-three.
That's the difference.
If you would like to win Mr. America, right?
Mr. Olympia in the pre-steroid era, at this body fat, you would have to be around ninety, ninety-five, or something like that.
And for our two-hundred-centimeter monster, it's one hundred thirty-one kilograms.
And for more realistic FFMI, it's one hundred ten kilograms.
So that's not super heavyweight, okay?
So that's not super, even if he is two hundred centimeters tall.
But, oh yeah, I'm sorry.
I looked at raw and not normalized, and we should be looking at normalized.
So with normalized, yeah, it's one hundred eight.
So you have jumped one category. You are not one hundred five.
And still not super heavy.
Okay, so this is where things get interesting.
But obviously,
it's interesting, but not very useful for us, because we are not bodybuilders.
So here is how much skeletal muscle mass is in each part of the body.
And here things start to get interesting, because legs and glutes, which are known for being very important for armwrestling, are fifty-five percent.
Trunk, twenty-seven.
Shoulders, almost ten.
Arms and forearms, like five point seven and two point nine.
As you see, the parts that are interesting for us, here and a little bit here, are not even half, not even a third.
It's a very, very small percentage of the whole muscle mass you carry.
So let's say that...
As armwrestlers, obviously, we are not going to max out our glutes, our legs, and our other muscle parts.
So let's say that we have a really solid FFMI of twenty-one point eight, like professional powerlifters or natural bodybuilders, which is unrealistically high for an armwrestler.
This is unrealistic, because if you are not hitting leg day at least once a week,
and who would ever do it? It's just not optimal.
But let's say we are all like that. We can be like that.
But for our arms, we're going to take Mr. Dillinger's FFMI. So we are getting twenty-eight.
We assume that we can grow these muscles more than Mr. America grew them in the pre-steroid era.
We can grow more muscle in our forearms and arms. We are just better.
Which obviously is not true, because bodybuilders are bigger.
But again, let's assume that we have Mr. Dillinger's FFMI.
So how much of the mass? Ooh, what have I done? Okay, I don't want it.
Stop it. Okay.
Anyway, I will not click anymore. So, okay. I don't want this. Okay. Sorry.
So from twenty-one point eight to twenty-eight, the difference in mass in the arms, without shoulders, is not even a kilo.
Okay? In the shoulders, it's less than a kilo.
In the upper body, it's what? Two and a half?
Even if we are talking about this freakishly genetic guy,
and taking him as our reference, which is crazy, how much muscle mass can we grow? Almost none. There is not much of it.
And this is interesting for us. I'm going to tell you a story. It overlaps with what Pascal told me in Switzerland when I met him. He said that through his whole career, since he started, he gained three kilograms of mass. And he is Pascal, right? So he's pretty good. He's not me or you. He's pretty good.
So this is the sauce, the crème de la crème of this video.
If we take the whole body at twenty-one point eight and our arms at twenty-eight, what body weight would you have?
Eighty-four.
And for a two-hundred-centimeter-tall guy, it's going to be one hundred nine kilos.
Which, as I said, is crazy.
And no one is going to reach this.
But let's assume we can, because we do our glutes and legs, and we have the FFMI of natural bodybuilders, plus our forearms.
So even someone with two hundred centimeters of height, like Vitaly, wouldn't be a super heavyweight. And Georgi was right.
He's just a tall, skinny guy without juice.
The problem is... All of them are tall, skinny guys without juice.
If you are not carrying an excessive amount of fat, Georgi, then that's it.
A human being is just not that huge.
That's why those categories actually look like that.
We have anomalies in this sport, but they are anomalies, and probably now you know what to think about them and can place yourself better in this world.
So yes, I'm going to give you the sources again if you want to check everything.
But I think this video was really needed, especially to give beginners an idea, because in my opinion, and I'm going to touch on this subject later, diet matters.
We're going to talk about a diet designed for armwrestling, because it's a little bit different than for bodybuilding and so on.
But you see, walking around like a pig is probably not going to give you any advantage. But anyway, take whatever you want from this video. I wanted to share it with you, and I think it's good timing after Georgi's statement. And that's it. Bye.